Martelli:
When you typically
are trying things out,
you want to see results
for what you're doing.
How do you see results?
Well, the--
If you're working
at the interactive shell,
then any expression you do
which has a value
that is not none,
it will be
represented for you
on the screen.
That is only useful
when you're trying things out.
When you're doing a program
but want to get
some extra output,
like for debugging
or understanding
what's going on,
there's a statement
called "print."
Very elementary.
It just puts the strings
into standard I/O.
You can use commas
to print multiple values.
And it will put spaces
between the values
and a new line at the end.
In real program, of course,
the way you do an output
is very, very different.
An excellent way to do output,
and very encouraged
in Google opinion,
is the logging package
of the Python standard library,
which basically
lets you log information
at different levels.
So you can tell the system,
"This is for debugging."
"This is for retrieve."
"This is a warning."
"This is an error."
"This is a fatal error."
So you can be selective
on what it is
that you're getting displayed.
If you're writing
a web application,
the typical way
you'll be seeing results
is by adding string
to some HTML response object.
If you're doing
a GUI application,
then there will be
GUI widgets
with their own methods
and so on.
So I'm not going to focus
on any of these.
I'm just going to use
print occasionally
to show you what is the result
that you're going to get.
And here's finally
some trivial examples.
Python has the world record
for the shortest
"Hello, world" program,
the most classic program
in the world.
You just have to use "print"
to get to standard output
and a string in quotes,
and that's all
there is to it.
Let's do some assignment.
"X = 23"
means X from now on
until further notice
is bound to the number 23.
So if you print X right now,
it emits
on standard output 23.
If you now say
"X = foo,"
then whatever X
was referring to,
X doesn't refer to anymore.
Maybe somebody else does.
X doesn't care.
The name X from now on
refers to the string "foo."
And I'm deliberately using
objects of different types,
like a number and a string,
to point out
that the name X per se
is totally at your disposal
to refer to anything you want.
What it is referring to
depends on what
you last assigned to it.
So now "print X"
emits "foo."
And you can also
remove the binding.
That's rarely done.
But if you want,
you can "del X."
This means from now on
the name X doesn't refer
to anything anymore.
Like if I'd never
assigned anything to it.
So if you now print X,
that's an error.
It raises an exception,
as we'll see
because X doesn't refer
to anything.
Well, what if you want X
to still be around
but not refer to anything?
Well, let's do it with Y.
That's what
you use "none" for.
"Y = none"
is different from "del Y."
It means
"Y refers to something."
"What?"
"Nothing."
I know, it's a bit--
So if you print Y,
instead of an error,
you get "none."
If you ever see a lot
of "none" in your output,
you're probably
doing something wrong,
but that's a good hint.
Okay, so there are
some pretty obvious
similarities
between Python and Java.
First of all,
in the implementation level,
although there are variants
in both cases,
they are both typically
compiled to bytecode.
Python compiles implicitly.
It's like it's got
a make engine built in.
But the typical result
is that a virtual machine,
or interpreter if you will,
will execute in a controlled
importable way
the bytecodes produced
by the compiler,
explicit or implicit
as it may be.
In both languages,
everything inherits
from object,
except it's spelled
with a lowercase O in Python.
That's hardly
a deep difference.
In Python, everything
is a first-class object.
So in Java,
a method or a class per se
does not constitute
an object.
In Python, it does.
There is nothing
that is just
a compile time construct
and doesn't have
an object responding to it.
Same for numbers
and so on.
Commonality,
a very deep, important,
absolutely crucial commonality
between Java and Python,
they both uniform
object reference semantics.
In other languages,
such as C++ or C,
when you say "A = B,"
this means
a lot of bits from B
are going to be copied over
into A.
There's a copy implied.
In Java or Python,
when you write "A = B,"
it means from now on
A refers to exactly
the same object
as B referred to
at that time.
So everything,
and this goes for assignment,
it goes for argument-passing,
goes for return values,
everything is about
having names refer to objects
as opposed
to having names
be boxes with bits in them.
Both languages
have garbage collection.
The classic
Python implementation
tries hard to collect garbage
much more proactively
than Java.
It doesn't wait
to collect garbage
until there's
a lot of garbage around.
It tries to collect garbage
as soon as it possible can,
basically to save
the run time memory
from going to waste.
Other implementations of Python,
however, don't do that.
A lot of what is in common
between Java and Python
are stuff outside
the language proper.
That's why I call them
"marginalia,"
but very important
to your everyday use.
Both have huge
standard libraries.
Both have enormous amounts
of third-party packages
and tools available.
Both let you do
introspection,
serialization,
threading,
all as part
of the standard libraries.
So if you're coming
from Java,
you'll have to learn
all the different ways
you can do those things
in CPython,
but the fact
that you can do them
is very much in common.
Now if you're coming
from C++ instead,
what's similar?
Well, they're
both multi-paradigm.
Java basically tries
to force you
into object-oriented
programming.
Python and C++
are happy if you do OOP,
but if you want to do
procedural programming
or generic programming
or a little bit
of functioning programming,
they'll happily
adjust to that.
Both languages
have multiple inheritance.
So you don't have to force
everything into a single tree.
You can use
any directed or cyclic graph
with caution
in both languages.
You can do
operator overloading.
The one thing that many
C++ programmer
think they can do
because they can do in C++
and they cannot do in Python
is to overload the assignment.
In Python,
assignment has exactly
the Java semantics always.
It's always
an object reference.
There is no way
for you to redefine
what assignment means.
Assignment is not
an operator in Python.
Everything else
that you can do in C++
and a lot of operators
that are not operators in C++
you can redefine in Python.
If you're very used to doing
generic programming in C++,
you know what signature based
polymorphism is.
In C++ it's also spelled
"templates."
Basically in Python
everything you're writing
is always a template
implicitly,
without any effort
on your part.
Very nice index.
So if you think
in terms of signatures,
Python supports signatures
implicitly.
Similarity--
The marginal similarity
between C++ and Python
is that both offer
abundant choices,
maybe even too many,
for just about everything
that's not an absolutely
core issue.
What GUI you want to use?
Basically any.
Web, other networking,
databases,
inter-program communication,
distributed processing.
The languages don't come
with a pre-bound solution.
You have to choose.
There's a huge possibility
of choices,
but sometimes
it can be penalizing
to have too many choices.
Now some people get surprised
when I point out
that Python
is the one language
that is most close to C.
Of course the syntax
is different,
but we know syntax
is only skin deep.
What is similar?
It's the spirit
of the language.
And we can tell
because the spirit of C
is officially acknowledged
as a part of the C Standard.
It's in the rationale
of the ISO C Standard.
And the spirit of C
consists of five principles.
Trust the programmer.
That's point one
of the spirit of C.
Don't try to second-guess
the programmer.
Trust him.
C does that.
Python does that.
C++ and Java do not.
They try to make sure
the programmer doesn't
get out of the sandbox.
You know, private,
protected, and things.
Don't stop the programmer
from doing
what needs to be done.
That's basically
a follow on from point one.
Keep the language
small and simple.
Don't add keywords
that are only needed
because you don't trust
the programmers,
like private.
Provide only one way
to do an operation.
This is something that C++
violates pretty badly
because it always
provides more than one way
because you can always
do things the C way
or you can do them
the object-oriented way
the generic way.
So there's typically
three ways to do anything.
In C philosophically
and Python philosophically,
there should be only one way.
And then the one bit
where Python
doesn't really match C,
the fifth most important
principle of C is be fast.
Python cares more about
programmer productivity
than raw speed.
So it's only
about 50% there.
It's got some very fast way
to do things,
but it always privileges
programmer productivity instead.
While C has
its own spirit
encoded in the standard,
Python doesn't have
an official standard,
but if you type
"import this"
at any interactive
Python prompt,
you'll get the equivalent--
the Zen of Python.
And this
is the one principle--
This is the way,
for example,
in which Python expresses
the only one way
to perform an operation.
It's a bit more verbose.
There should be one,
and preferably only one way
to do it.
So it's more clear
in the Python formulation
that this is an objective,
a target,
a stretch goal.
It's not something
we can actually do.
Nobody's going to stop you
from saying,
"Two plus three
or three plus two,"
which are two ways to perform
the same operation
in a trivial sense.
It would make the language
more complicated
to try and forbid it.
So now that we've seen
similarities
of Python to some languages
you might be familiar with,
let's see--
So what's different?
If this is in common,
this is in common,
what is not in common
with any of them?
Well, there's two points.
First of all, Python has
very spare syntax,
no ornamentation.
It applies,
Tufte's principle,
no wasted pixels.
If you don't know
who Edward Tufte is,
I suggest you should
buy his masterpiece.
He's got several books out,
but "The Visual Display
of Quantitative Information"
is an immortal masterpiece.
It's a book on how do we
display information graphically?
And the core principle
is every pixel is precious.
Don't put a pixel there unless
it communicates information.
So for example,
why does Python respect
Tufte's principle?
Well, you don't put braces
or begin and end keywords
around a block.
You just indent it.
Don't waste any pixel.
You don't put parenthesis
around a condition
in an "if" or "while."
Why should you?
You just write it
like "if, space,
condition, colon."
That's it.
No parenthesis.
No wasted pixels.
In general, Python
doesn't like punctuation.
It uses
very spare punctuation
and prefers to go
for keywords instead.
And then there's the semantics.
Of course syntax
is what strikes you first,
but deep down the semantics
are much more important.
Python typing is strong
but dynamic.
That is it's strong.
It's stronger than C
for example.
You cannot say,
"Take these bits
which used to be this type
and make believe they're
this other type instead."
With a cast,
you cannot do that.
An object has integrity.
It's very strong typing.
About as strong as Java,
I would say, or a bit more.
But names have no types.
A name is a name
is a name.
The object has a type,
and the name
refers to the object.
So at any given time,
the name will be referring
to something with a type
but will not have
any type itself.
And this is also
known as "duck typing."
That is,
if it walks like a duck
and quacks like a duck,
it's a duck.
That is not necessarily
the case.
A few years ago a species
that had been identified
as a duck sometimes
in memorial
was actually revealed
by DNA analysis to be a goose,
A goose that had evolved
to basically
live in exactly the same
ecological niches as ducks have
in other the places.
I'm told it even
tasted like duck
if you cooked it.
Well, so it's not necessarily
true that it is a duck,
but it's very true that
you could treat it as a duck
for just about every purpose
in your life.
There's no declarations.
Declarations
are great for lovers.
I want to make
a love declaration to my wife.
But in life,
what you want is action,
not empty words,
not declarations.
You want statements,
actions.
And that's
what Python gives you.
Everything is a statement.
Everything
is a first-class object.
No need to distinguish,
is a function an object?
Is a class an object?
Yes.
A module is an object,
a package is an object.
Everything is an object.
The focus in Python
is always
on the very high level,
on the programmer
productivity.
How does a programmer
think about his problem?
We do try to support
bit twiddling at lower levels,
but that's
a second-order of priority,
while in seen particular
it's very much
the top priority
to support the way
the machine works.
So about duck typing again,
this is an alternative
interpretation
of the expression
"duck typing,"
which would be connected
with not having to do
the typing yourself
but training a duck
to do it for you.
I think it would take
quite a while
to train the duck,
but if you can make it
that should certainly improve
your productivity.
Back to technical issues.
Flow control,
there's basically
four flow control statement--
if, while, for, and with.
You're probably familiar
with "if" and "while."
And this "for"
is more equivalent
to the "for each"
of Java.
But, um,
what you should notice
is instead of going
"else if,"
there's an "elif,"
collapsed "elif,"
that you can have
in an "if"
and the optional "else."
Loops, beside
the "break" and "continue,"
just like in C and so on,
also have an optional "else."
That's somewhat unusual
in programming languages.
The point is the "else" branch
gets executed
if the "while" loop
terminates naturally,
not by a break.
That is very handy sometimes.
And the "for" has exactly
the same features.
Now, "with"
is a relatively new statement,
so if you want to use it
in 2.5,
you will require
an import from the future.
That's how we express
changes in Python
that are not 100%
backwards compatible.
We require the programmer
to import them
from the future.
That's because "with"
has become a keyword
with this feature.
We'll deal with that
when we treat exception.
But it's a very important--
It's a very important
new control statement.
So then we have data.
We have simple types
and container types
that are built in.
Simple types
are all immutable,
that is the number 23
is the number 23
is the number 23,
and it will never
be any other number.
The name that you're using
at some point
to refer to 23,
you can use later
to refer to 24.
That doesn't mean
you've changed the number.
The mathematicians
would never approve.
Uh, one thing I should notice
is that Python
has complex numbers,
which is very unusual
these days.
It used to be standard.
That's maybe part of why
Python is so popular
for scientific computing
as well,
'cause it's got
complex numbers,
which are very handy
in some kind
of technical
and scientific computing.
And it's got
the star, star operator,
which is a raise to power,
which is also
extremely handy.
Um, and then strings.
Unfortunately two kinds,
plain and Unicode.
I say "unfortunately"
because, well,
it's better than only having
the plain strings like Ruby.
But it's definitely inferior
to only having
the Unicode strings like Java
because these days
we all want to have
internationalized stuff.
This means you should
support Unicode.
This is a big simplification
that we're doing
in Python three,
which is now in alpha.
It's gonna be
in beta soon.
Removing the distinction
and only having Unicode strings
just like Java.
You can concatenate,
repeat, format.
Format is like
a "printf" in C.
It's a very rich language.
And they're
immutable sequences.
So you can take the length.
You can use brackets
to index or slice.
You can do a "for" loop.
And just like in Java script,
each item in a string
is a character
but there's
no character types,
so each character
is a length-one string.
Take care about that.
And of course there's
a huge amount of methods.
How do you find out
all the methods
that you can use
on a Python string?
Well, this is how you discover
a method on anything.
You do the,
at the interactive prompt,
dir, D-I-R,
of the object
you are interested in.
In this case,
quote, something, quote.
And you get
a huge list of names
of all the attributes,
including methods,
of that object.
You will notice
that a lot of them
have two underscores
before and after.
We'll come back to that
in the second part.
And others
are just identifiers,
like "center."
So now you ask yourself,
so what's that "center" thing?
And this
is where help comes.
You can "help,
open paren,
something you want
help about."
Note that is not center.
It's "some string, dot, center."
Because you want
the attribute or method
center of a string,
not of some other object.
So you have to say that.
And this is what it tells you.
It's return string
centered in a string
of a certain length,
padded in a certain way.
Once you've found out
the basic guidance,
well, then you experiment.
That's what the interactive
interpreter is from.
You try "center"
with a fill character
that's more visible,
like a plus.
And yes, "ciao"
in a field of ten
is "three plusses,
ciao, three plusses."
In field of three,
does it truncate?
No, it leaves it alone.
What if the field is odd?
Well, the extra one goes
at the beginning and so on.
You don't find all of these
finely detailed in "help."
You do find them
in "Python in a Nutshell,"
plug, plug.
But you don't need it
because you can always
find them out interactively,
experimentally.
And that's a great way
to learn things
because you actually
try them out.
Learn by doing.
And then we have
container types.
Container types
include tuple,
which are immutable sequences,
and lists,
which are mutable sequences.
They're typically denoted
with parenthesis
versus square brackets.
You also need a comma here,
otherwise "(23)."
would just be
the number 23
because the parenthesis
are used in expressions as well.
You don't need,
although you could have,
an extra comma here.
And then we have
set in frozenzet,
which are mutable
and immutable
simple hash tables,
just collections of stuff.
And then you have the dict,
or dictionary,
which is a map from key
to value by a hash table.
And all containers
have a length,
number of items in them.
You can loop
on each of them.
And you can check if something
is part of the container,
membership testing.
Typically every container
has many, many, many,
many methods.
And in case of sets,
also some operators
'cause you can do union
and intersection of sets.
Sequences in particular
are lists and tuples
as well as strings.
You can multiply
by an integer,
meaning repeat them
a certain number of times.
And you can concatenate.
You can concatenate
two sequences of the same type.
You can index by writing
the index in brackets.
You can slice by writing,
"start, colon, end"
and possibly
a third colon step or stride.
That is, for example,
ciao of 2 is A.
Indexes always start
from zero,
so C, I, A.
Third one instead of two.
Ciao three to one
by minus one.
So you start at the three,
which is the O
and go backwards,
because we've got
the minus on the stride,
until you hit
one excluded.
The end is always excluded.
If you've read
Andrew Koenig's masterpiece
"C Traps and Pitfalls"--
If you haven't,
you should,
whatever language
you're programming in.
And if you have,
you will remember
the chapters he devotes
to explaining why every loop
should be start included
and excluded.
And Python uses
it very widely.
Now, lists
are mutable sequences.
Strings are immutable.
They're built in.
But lists are mutable,
meaning you can assign
to an index or a slice.
Assigning to an indexing
just means
whatever was there before,
now there is another thing.
It's like assigning
to a name.
Assigning to a slice
can make the string longer--
sorry, the list longer
or shorter
because you can assign
to a slice
a longer list
than the slice
or a shorter list
than the slice.
And things will smoothly
change to suit you.
Dictionaries and sets
are not sequences.
There is no intrinsic order.
As I mentioned,
they're hash tables.
So they're in whatever order
is nice for retrieval.
So there is no slicing
because there
is no way to say,
"What's the first
or the second?"
And so on.
You can iterate,
and you will be
given the items
in a random-looking order.
There's a method
to this madness,
but it's the hash function
so it's far from transparent.
More about containers.
Containers have methods
that can be classified
in two general roles--
mutating and non-mutating.
A mutating method
typically does its work
by altering the container,
inserting something,
removing something.
And typically
it returns "none"
because there is no natural
result for that.
For example, the append
method of list,
add one at the end.
The add method of sets
one more item.
The update
method of dictionary
merge another dictionary
into this one.
They will all return "none"
and change the specific object
in which you're calling them.
A few mutating methods
have a natural result
and therefore return it.
For example, "pop" removes
typically the last,
but you can tell it which one,
element of a list
and gives it back to you.
"Pop" in a dictionary
removes an arbitrary item
and gives it back to you.
Setdefault on dictionary,
that's a bit more complicated.
We'll see an example later.
But again,
it has a return.
And then there's
non-mutating methods
that, like, necessarily
return a result
because they don't
do any changes.
Um, sets have a variant
which only supports
the non-mutating method,
the frozenset.
Dictionary doesn't,
but it has another variant
in module collections,
which we'll see
in examples later,
which has a default value.
Other important containers
in the collections module
include
the doubled ended queue,
which basically
is like a list
but internally
organized differently
so it's just as fast
to access from either end
and rotate.
We don't have
a priority queue
or heap type.
We only have functions
that treat a list
as a priority queue.
Not sure if you're
familiar with heaps,
but suppose we,
for some reason, like we're--
For fanatic Java programmers
and things,
everything should be wrapped
in a class.
We want to make
a priority type.
How do we do that?
Well, rushing far ahead
to things we'll see
in the second half,
such as classes and methods
and modules.
Well, first of all
we import the "heapq" module,
which gives us
all the functions we need.
And then we basically
write a class called "heap"
and everything get explicitly
from object
with all the methods
we want.
Some of them start and end
with double underscores.
Those are special methods
which have very special roles.
Other just identifiers.
You will notice "self"
as the first parameter
of each and every method.
That means
that the object itself
in which the method
has been called.
Some are others.
So, for example,
we first thing we need to do
is get some content,
make it into a list,
assign it as a variable,
and make sure it is a heap.
To make sure that a list
is a heap,
"heapq.heapify"
basically does whatever
permutation is needed.
And then this makes available
the "push" and "pop" function,
which keep the heap property,
the priority heap property,
adding and removing an item.
And the replace,
which does
heap push and a pop.
So it takes the previous stop
and puts something else
in its place,
maintaining the heap property.
And this basically
would be the hard work.
And we just need to call
the functions
"heappush," "heappop,"
and "heapreplace,"
provided by
the "heapq" module.
And then
we have some special--
Okay, "_init_"
is the initializer.
So what's the content,
what's the initial content
of this thing.
"_len_" is how do I
compute the length
of this container?
In disguise, I simply--
It's the same as the length
of the list it's using.
How do I iterate
in this containing?
Same as you iterate
on the list it's using.
How do I represent
this container?
In this case,
I'm representing it
as "heap, open paren,
its contents."
So representation
of its contents.
So I could add many more
special methods,
but basically all I'm doing
is delegating properly.
The special method
I'm calling
has underscores
before and behind.
And I'm delegating
appropriately
to a built-in function
that will internally invoke
the special method
on this other list.
I also have truthiness.
Comparisons, tests,
and truth-like value.
I can do
all the normal comparisons.
You will have to be away
of the distinction
between equality
and identity.
It's spelled "two equals"
versus "is"
as opposed to three equals
as in other languages.
Orders of course.
Membership is also considered
an elementary comparison.
And you can chain comparisons.
That's pretty special
to Python.
So the expression
"3 < = X < 9"
means exactly
what it should obviously mean.
X is at the same time
greater or equal three
and less than nine.
It goes left to right.
So like in Java script,
the falsy concept
applies to any number
that's zero,
an empty string, none,
and empty container,
and the special value False
with an uppercase F here,
which is the same thing
as the bool of zero.
And everything else is true.
That's a very optimistic
view of life.
It's mostly everything true
except some very few
special objects
specifically identified
as false.
And then
there's some operator
like "and," "or," "not."
We all spell them out.
Remember, we don't
really like punctuation.
So what you would spell
as "&&" in C,
you'll spell "A-N-D"
in Python.
But the semantics
are the same.
And then if you want to do
on more than two at a time,
you can use "any" and "all"
to return
a Boolean value.
So we'll see some examples.
Okay, exceptions,
kind of like in Java.
Accept that some anomalies
that are not really errors
should also
raise an exception.
And you can also raise them
explicitly with "raise."
When you raise an exception,
assuming nothing
is catching it,
it keeps going
along the call stack
killing functions
as it goes.
It's kind of scary,
horror, movie-like image.
And if it goes all the way,
the whole program,
the whole world gets destroyed.
Um, "try/except,"
as opposed to "try/catch"
as in other languages,
is how you make sure
that anything happening,
any exception raised
in the try clause,
is handled
in the proper way.
"Try/final" is exactly
like in Java,
but is whatever exception
or non-exception
is happening in the try
make sure that at the very end
you do this and that.
And then we have
the new "with" statement.
I'm particularly
fond of it.
It implements an idiom
which is very familiar
to C++ programmers--
resource acquisition
is initialization,
which is misspelled here.
It's R-A-I-I.
Or "as initialization"
instead of "is"
works just as well
as saves me from admitting
to a misspelling.
So since it makes with,
W-I-T-H, into a keyword,
to make sure we don't break
compatibility with the past,
it's only enabled it
at the very top of the module
you start with "from future
import with statement."
And future has underscores
below before and after
just to make sure it's
obviously a very special case.
So if you do that,
you can, um, make sure
that something is initialized
at the start of a block
and properly finalized
when that block's exit.
No matter how it exits.
So it's syntactically
very elegant
but semantically just like
a try/finally.
The nice thing
is that the finalizer
is something that you can code
once and for all.
In C++ you do it
as a destructor.
In Python we want
to distinguish two cases
or let it distinguish
two cases.
Is the object being finalized
after a normal termination?
Or is it being finalized
after an exception propagates?
C++ doesn't
let you distinguish.
A destructor is a destructor
is a destructor.
You have to resort
to horrid tricks.
But it's obvious that
you do want to distinguish.
Consider a transaction
in a database.
Well, you want to know
whether the transaction
is done correctly
or incorrectly,
'cause in one case
you do end work and commit
and in the other one
you want to roll back, okay?
You can't do that
with RAAI in C++,
but you can in Python
because the exit special method
gets stalled whether
an exception has occurred.
So let me give some examples.
This is the most simple one.
With open some file
as F.
Use F as you will.
In this case,
I'm looping over the file,
so I'm getting a line
at a time
and printing
the third character,
actually the fourth one.
Suppose this either
ends normally
because the file is done
or it raises an exception
because there's a line
that's too short.
So a line of three
is out of bounds indexing.
No matter what,
F gets closed
at the end of this block.
Similarly,
say you have a lock somewhere
in a threading system,
"with the lock do something"
means the lock gets acquired
before the critical section
is entered
and will always get released
as soon as this is done
no matter whether
it's smooth or not.
And this one--
The "contextlib"
is a method that is a module
from the central library
that gives you all kind of tools
to do these kind of things.
But it's basically--
"Closing" makes sure
that the close is called
at the end of the block.
So you do a connection
to a database
and open a cursor.
And make sure
the cursor is closed
and the database connection
is closed.
So one peculiarity
of Python
is we love to have
a simple statement,
a high level statement,
explaining terms
of lower level ones.
So this is what "for" means.
It means make
an iterator and loop,
calling the next method
of the iterator
until a stop iteration
exception,
in this case terminate.
We also have syntax
to use this as expression,
as a simple expression
like that.
A certain expression
for everything
in a certain iterable
with optional clauses.
Or if you use brackets,
then you make a list
out of it,
and it's called
"the list comprehension."
And let me give some example
of using general expressions
with accumulators,
that is function that can
take any number of items
and basically
process them all.
One of the simplest
is "sum".
Give sum any collection
of numbers,
it will just sum them all
and return the sum.
So how do we know
how many items
say of any generic
type of class?
It may not support
the length.
Well, we sum one
for everything in the item.
So we basically count.
It's as simple as that.
And then we can call it
on the generic expression.
See?
Every X in the range
from zero--
0 included
from 99 excluded,
which equal--
which module five
equals itself, module seven.
Very simple.
Other accumulators,
"any," I mentioned it before.
Is any X greater than five
among the Xs?
See how natural this is.
Our all(X > Y> Z)
for X, Y, Z.
"Zip" is for parallel iteration
along containers.
It actually makes a list.
So you can use
the itertools,
which gives you
an iterator zip, "izip."
And in this case,
it must be the same context.
Other example, "max."
What's the highest index
at which
there is a positive number?
"Enumerate" given a sequence,
gives you the index, item,
index, item, index, item.
So you loop on index
and item
and take the highest I
for which X is greater
than zero.
And this takes us
to halfway point.
So we do have
three minutes and 51 seconds
before formal break.
So if there's any questions
that you'd rather ask now
rather than an hour from now,
please go to the mike
and we'll do that.
Well, if there's
no question,
I can take a short break.
[applause]